this while we've had a lot to celebrate
this holiday weekend law enforcement has
remained
very busy tonight authorities
investigating the sixth murder in the
valley
over the past three days madison
kimbrough joining us live tonight
madison you gained some insight
on what may be causing that uptick
brian we spoke to several people who
believe the lifting of coveted
restrictions along with the fourth of
july holiday
is behind in the reason of this
disturbing trend
it used to be nice around here but now
with the shooting
oh no i got to go over the weekend
shooting after
shooting as a reported five homicides
took place across the valley
on sunday north las vegas police say
seven people were injured in a shootout
that left two men dead prior to that
three others were killed on saturday in
separate incidents
i kind of want to get out and explore
but at the same time it kind of makes me
nervous
and this afternoon made six as one man
lost his life after he was shot
in this northeast valley neighborhood
metro has not confirmed any further
details but this section of the
neighborhood was blocked off for hours
resident michelle wiggins says it's not
safe for her or her grandkids
it's not safe for them because they play
all up and down the blocks
and this happened in the daytime as for
the trend this weekend people across the
valley feel that the holiday weekend
combined with the lifting of coveted
restrictions has made people lash out
i think the pandemic restrictions being
lighter than the past few months might
have something to do with it people were
cooped up so long and now they're
getting out and getting crazy because at
a holiday maybe more people more
drinking
now as for the shooting that happened
earlier today on the northeast side
of the valley we are still awaiting
details from metro so we will keep you
updated as soon as we learn more
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now